♪ ♪ ♪
- En 2022, les chefs de partis
sont partout sur les médiast
l'humour...
- Fromage en grain
en crottes? Fromage "skouik
- ... d'autres expliquent
leurs engagements.
- Ça c'est notre plan
pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques.
vraiment?
ÉMILE ROY,
réalisateur et youtubeur
- C'est pas juste de faire
des très courtes vidéos drnes,
c'est aussi de parler de
ses idées. Puis d'expérience,
les jeunes adultes sont prêts
à écouter des contenus plus
longs, où on parle d'idées,
où on parle vraiment
de propositions.
- Des prvironnement,
particulièrement.
- On aimerait voir
l'environnement comme une
priorité absolue. On aimerait
programmes, qui sont peut-être
aussi drastiques que les mesures
qui ont été prises pendant
- Un futur angoissant, qui
affecte la santé m
jeunes, un enjeu qui revient
dont l'anxiété est accentuée
par le coût de l
SACHA-WILKY MERAZIL, 27 ans
justement qui se demandent,
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir
la chance de leurs parents
et de leurs grands-parents?
ne proposent rien pour
le portefeuille de
- Ce serait bien d'avoir une
annonce pour des allocations
dédiées aux jeunesdirectes..dir.
des victimes directes dis-je
bien, deon.343434343434343434344
ans sont presqu'aussi nombreux
que les 65 ans et plus.
Mais en 2018, seulement
un jeune sur deux avait voté.
Élections Québe
- Allô tout le monde,
allez vo
- Pour ce faire, les jeunes
de leur pouvoir politique.
- C'est tellement une partie
importante du vote, qui était
tout simplement pas représentée.
Donc allez voter le 3 octobre,
- Voilà, l'appel est lancé.
Ici Marie-Josée
Paquett
Radio-Canada Mont